cranberries are a staple in many
thanksgiving meals whether as a sauce or
part of a dish but this year the trip
these little fruits made to your table
was a bit more challenging warmer
weather and record rainfall caused by
climate change mean the berries grow
more slowly eric fisher chief
meteorologist at our boston station wbz
got waist deep at a massachusetts farm
to find out how growers are coping with
the ever-changing weather patterns
brilliant as the famous fall foliage
cranberries paint a striking contrast
against the blue skies of massachusetts
does it ever get old wading through a
feast of thanksgiving dinner actually i
love this you know
it's cool to be out here like this
though the scene is picturesque as ever
for 40-year bog veteran glenn reed and
growers across new england getting to
the finish line this year has been a
battle the last couple years have been
we thought strange as far as weather
goes and stuff but i think this year has
really been
the defining year you name it we've had
it
first it was the record-setting deluge
of rain that pounded down throughout the
spring and summer cranberries are
floated for an easier harvest but it's
not their natural state then came the
hottest summer on record the problem
with that
is the berries are sitting on your bog
soaking wet and now you have a very hot
day you start to get rot
and it's culminating with one of the
warmest falls on record as growers
waited for cold nights that never came
middle of september you start to usually
have colder nights
this year we didn't do that but that is
what starts to trigger that coloring
it's really the same chemical reaction
that happens to the leaves in the fall
through early november reed says only
five nights got to frosty levels they've
never waited longer for the chill to
start setting in crews that were booked
to start in mid-september had to sit and
wait until october to get started
another costly burden in an industry
with already slim margins when we look
at the statistics and we look at the
charts and the graphs and we say yes
it's getting warmer fall in particular
here in new england is warming
is that something you feel something
that has a grower you've noticed oh yeah
we definitely noticed that the climate
is changing down the road at the umass
cranberry station hillary sandler and
her team are hoping to help growers like
reed to adapt this is a new variety
trial that we just planted this past
june
sandler oversees rows of test bogs
finding ways to increase yield and
create varieties that can weather warmer
temperatures not just summer and fall
but winter too
deep cold has become more scarce and a
centuries-old tradition has disappeared
along with it it's really been much more
noticeable to me say in the past 10
years when i first started in 1990 every
winter we would flood our bogs and we
would get ice that would form out here
and we would flood them to prevent some
winter injury we rarely get ice formed
now
something reed and everyone else we
spoke to have noticed as well always
used to be something i mean growing up
we used to skate on all these bugs
playing hockey all went along we don't
do that anymore
at the end of the production all this
change simply means there's a cranberry
crushed with thanksgiving coming up
everyone wants their cranberries
yesterday
we're doing the best we can to to get
them out there
whether your team straight from the can
or fresh made will you be paying for the
burden of increasingly erratic weather
this one here that's a lot of tape here
brian wick executive director of the
cape cod cranberry growers association
says that may not be the case the
consumer is only going to pay so much
for their food
we like to think that crammers are a
staple that everyone's eating them every
day but that's not necessarily the case
if the price goes beyond what they're
willing to pay for that and so in a year
was staffing shortages supply chain
issues and hot wet weather cutting
yields it all falls back on growers like
reed who will have to find a new way
forward we're going to have to adjust
the way we grow because we're not going
to change the way the weather is for cbs
mornings i'm eric fisher in wareham
massachusetts
you know i love cranberries but they
were never a staple of our thanksgiving
table because it's french caribbean and
chinese right uh our family seafood
egg seafood pie but my brother-in-law
chris loves my sister's husband he loves
cranberries and he likes the canned
stuff yeah which is like the best
eggs michelle
it is the best
and bring it for you saturday no no i
know i have both i've made both okay but
you know i'm a girl from the hood so
you know that was weird
to do with it people in the hood like
fresh cranberries if they can get it
yeah but well
i don't know
we're not gonna go to bed but what's
really spectacular about it is it has
its own unique taste it has a memory
embedded in my mind and my grandmother's
house and she was not cooking any fresh
cranberries it takes too long in her
mind she's pulling it out of the cage
all right okay makes good sense there
michelle miller as always